media porca [ __ ] ahia ahia ahia misti
golosissimo qua va beh
che idea del cazzo bella certi ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo dio sono
farisei
questa è una sedia da gaming ho deciso
di fare questo il suo blog il challenge
perché l'acqua è prendersi come sbatte
su questo scoglio qua mi sento proprio
gli schizzi che mi arrivano al cervello
e non è piacevole questo lo posso
assicurare però vabbè perché noi siamo
youtuber
professionisti è la prima te faccio un
blog al mare tra l'altro mi disse
beh mica come non mi è venuta quest'idea
prima ci sono delle cose che sono
successe ultimamente che non vi ho
spiegato una di queste ho fatto una
specie di apparizione nel video di una
youtuber americana che ha tipo 4 milioni
di iscritti anche lei ero all'e3 di los
angeles e ho visto questa che bloccava
io sapevo chi era lei ovviamente non
sapeva chi ero io e quindi mentre stava
frugando facendo un blog proprio serio
io le sono comparso dietro in questa
scena 43 quindi derby è già un bel
bikini
[Musica]
non fate domande è stato è stato il mio
momento di gloria poi ovviamente ci sono
stati tanti cameo di vari youtubers
internazionali tipo quello che marco era
il copy di nuovo talk che conoscete
tutti quanti però vabbè forse era meglio
sorvolare su questo punto quindi ragazzi
oggi da un botto di tempo che non lo
faccio vorrei fare il fare risponde
se dio esiste e allora le domande di
oggi fa vj stai con giulia senna no non
sto con giulia penna basta fare questa
domanda non sto con giulia penna non
stiamo insieme
era un video per capri ponte dove
abbiamo recitato il bacio
quindi non stiamo insieme punto quale
passione ai oltre youtube
a molti non lo sanno però io questo lo
sanno magari le persone che mi seguono
da un po più di tempo
io suono il suo suono sul suono
oltre al citofono sono lounge pub che è
una specie di una specie di quadrato che
c'ha i tasti e quando lo schiacci fai la
musica tipo skrillex
e per suonare musiche di m in poche
parole non è un vero e proprio strumento
ma mi piace suonare 4 bari stiamo
arrivando ai 4 milioni velocissimi come
ti senti questa la domanda avete fatto
tutti ultimamente
devi stare caldo granda è sempre un
casino dire come mi sento quando
raggiungono traguardi perché dal momento
in cui siamo arrivati a un milione tipo
2 o 3 anni fa manco mi ricordo più ho
messo proprio di contare i traguardi
perché siamo troppi siamo troppi vi dico
soltanto che molti mi avete chiesto
anche che speciale ho intenzione di fare
per i 4 milioni e prendiamo la più
pallida idea
la cosa peggiore che ti arrivata nei
pacchi questa l'avete chiesto
nell'ultimo fa vi risponde che risale a
secoli fa c'erano ancora i mammut
la cosa peggiore che mi arrivata nei
pacchi grazie credo fosse un pezzo di
formaggio il problema che io non ho
aperto quel pacco per tipo un anno
quindi era giusto un attimo ammuffito
c'erano allora e che non ve lo voglio
spiegare ragazzi era veramente triste di
limone resti anima si erano le domande
più votate nell'ultimo fa vi risponde vi
faccio notare l'eleganza ecco perché ho
smesso di farlo
il viaggio che più ti è rimasto nel
cuore piace che prima rimasta nel cuore
direi il giappone anche perché ci sono
stato una truffa stati un paio di
settimane sono state le due settimane
più belle della
mia vita perché sono innamorato del
giappone anche perché ho sempre guardato
un sacco di anni ne ho letto un botto di
manga e quindi a me la cultura
giapponese proprio piace tanto e adesso
stiamo per tornarci con i nei non vedo
l'ora di tornarci raramente il giappone
e tanta tantissima roba il tuo artista
italiano preferito questa è la domanda
che mi fate in tanti i notai non seguo
tanto la musica italiana
e ci sarà motivo che cantano
è bello figo ti senti ancora con i tuoi
amici dopo che hai avuto successo questa
è una domanda che hanno continuato a
fare mi tutti nel corso degli anni e non
ho mai capito il perché la risposta
ovviamente sì perché non dovrei sentirmi
con gli amici dopo che che ho raggiunto
un sacco di spiriti io sono sempre io
non è che io sono cambiato e solo che
molti mi fanno questa domanda pensando
che io non lo so abbia abbandonato in
qualche modo le amicizie
invece no io continuo quindi ragazzi
queste in sintesi erano le domande che
mi avete fatto nell'ultimo fa vi
risponde me l'ero scritte sul telefono
perché ovviamente non poteva portarmi un
computer portatile
anche perché a quest'ora sarebbe sarebbe
stato da buttare però adesso butto solo
il telefono fortunatamente quindi
ragazzi questa era il blog che ho fatto
qui sono in liguria comunque nel caso ve
lo stesse chiedendo ho voluto
improvvisare questo blog perché mi
sembrava carino farlo sulle sponde del
mare perché volevo fare una roma un po
romantica
però la mia schiena non è romantica
manco per il cazzo e manco il mio culo e
romantico in questo momento quindi
ragazzi cosa inserire più sull'argomento
è un mi piace anche va risolta anche
coniglio da tenere scrizione madonna che
sollievo alzare il culo di qua
porca vacca sono fradicio
probabilmente se mi tuffavo dentro ero
più ero più asciutto di adesso sai se
rischiate di ci vediamo al prossimo
video da reja
perché proprio adesso deve passare
l'elicottero li mortacci le squadre
quello che le passa l'elicottero mentre
faccio lordi li mortacci della tua elica
[Musica]